a massive new investment in the global
fight against covid
on the first full day of president
biden's first overseas trip
in office the u.s announced a deal to
donate 500 million doses of the pfizer
vaccine to lower income countries
and african union nations it's part of a
mission to restore
america's leadership role on the world
stage nancy cordes is in cornwall
england for us where the president's
trip is beginning nancy good morning to
you where it's already midday
so he's meeting with british prime
minister boris johnson today and then
he'll attend the g7
summit what's the overall message
well the message is that the u.s wants
to be the global leader
when it comes to fighting covid with the
largest ever
donation of vaccine from a single
country
and we're told that president biden will
challenge the other world leaders
gathered here in cornwall today
to step up their donations as well
news of the donation was time to
coincide with president biden's uk
arrival
we're going to make it clear that the
united states is
back pfizer says the 500 million doses
acquired by the u.s will go to
92 low and lower middle income countries
and the 55 member states of the african
union
while the u.s has fully vaccinated
nearly 43 percent of its population
many other countries like afghanistan
vietnam and rwanda
haven't even hit one percent we have to
end covet 19 not just at home which
we're doing
but everywhere the president kicks off
his diplomatic tour today with a
one-on-one meeting with british prime
minister boris johnson
the conservative leader has applauded
some of mr biden's early moves
it's great by the way that joe has
brought
the united states back into the paris
climate change
accords but the two do not see eye to
eye on brexit
or uk relations with northern ireland
both will come up today
still it's sure to be a love fest
compared to next week's meeting between
mr biden
and russian president vladimir putin
president biden stepped up his tough
talk wednesday
amid skepticism about the timing and
wisdom of a putin summit
just in the past few weeks russia-based
hackers have forced
multiple u.s businesses to pay millions
in ransom
by holding their data hostage the united
states will respond
in a robust and meaningful way when the
russian government engages in harmful
activities
but that summit is still a week away and
today we're told a big topic of
conversation
is going to be transatlantic air travel
right now
most uk residents still aren't allowed
to travel to the u.s
due to covid and many u.s residents have
to quarantine for five to ten days
when they come here so president biden
prime minister johnson are going to be
talking about
whether and when to ease those
restrictions gail
nancy thank you